ونذهب الى سوريا الان مقتل واكثر من 15
ايرانيا بينهم ضابطان في قصف اسرائيلي
يعتبر الثاني هذا العام على سوريا وفق ما
كشفته وسائل الاعلام سوريه معارضه هذه
المره القصف الاسرائيلي الطالب بشكل رئيسي
حي كفر سوسه في جنوب غربي دمشق واستهدف
مدرسه ايرانيه وشقه سكنيه كان يتواجد فيها
ضباط ايرانيون كانوا يعقدون اجتماعا في
المنطقه مما ادى الى مقتل سته منهم ومن
بينهم ضابطان رفعاء المستوى بحسب المصادر
الهجوم الاسرائيليه مشاهدينا ايضا مواقع
الميليشيات الايرانيه في منطقه السيده
زينب
ومحيطي الفرقه الاولى في منطقه الكسوه
جنوب دمشق اسفر عن مقتل تسعه من عناصر
الميليشيات الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
عندي طاقه للبيع
لا حول ولا قوه
ا لم تتاخر بالرد لتوضح ان الهجوم
الاسرائيليه على دمشق استهدف عده مواقع
عسكريه ونفذ على مرحلتين الاولى في دمشق
في نفس الموقع الذي قتل فيه عماد مغنيه
اما الثانيه فكانت في السويداء نافيه وقوع
اضرار في مجمع للخميني او المدرسه
الايرانيه في دمشق اما الجانب السوري فاكد
الرقم نفسه وهو 15 قتيلا ولكنه هويه
القتلى مشيرا الى انهم مدنيون وبينهم
عسكري في حصيله هي الاعلى في العاصمه
السوريه نتيجه ضربه مماثله وفق ما افاد
المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان
[موسيقى]